votre entreprise Sierra asset management a
reçu des paiements de 22 virgule cinq
millions de dollars de SNC Lavra pour d'autres
choses rien à voir avec cela rien
à voir avec cela rien à voir avec cette
période comment était-ce
possible pour quoi quel était le travail pour
bien  nous avions comme je l'ai dit nous avions des
discussions en cours entre pour interpréter pour le
conseil et pour développer des entreprises
en Afrique et franchement quand je l'ai
regardé j'avais dit à SNC j'ai dit aux
joueurs que si j'allais faire du
conseil  Je le ferais pour des
contrats de 5 ans à environ cinq millions par
an et je travaillerais pour essayer de trouver des
entreprises pour eux, rappelez-vous que toutes les
entreprises que je pourrais produire
seraient probablement des entreprises d'un milliard de dollars
et j'ai été surpris qu'ils en fait
étaient intéressés par cela, mais comme j'ai
pu le voir d'après ce qu'ils voulaient
réaliser dans le monde en développement et
déjà l'intérêt de conclure des
accords, ces chiffres ne sont pas aussi
fantastiques qu'ils l'ont vu  avec qui avez-vous
eu la discussion sur le fait que vous auriez dû
toucher cinq millionnaires, je ne vais pas
entrer dans certains de ceux à ce
stade, c'est que jokah bar, je ne vais pas
entrer dans ceux avec ces étapes parce que je
pense que ces domaines  cela
sortira, mais parce qu'il y a une action
en justice impliquée et parce que je vais certainement
intenter une action en justice contre d'
autres d'accord à la fin de cette journée, je
préférerais que même si certains de ces
domaines restent privés maintenant, je sais que la
Commission Charbonneau était assez ouverte  en
termes de ce qu'ils ont dit, mais je ne
pense pas que je vais faire la même chose, d'
accord, mais je veux être
parfaitement clair ici, votre compréhension était que
vous vous attendiez à quelque
chose d'environ cinq millions de
dollars par an  sur les divers
accords de conseil oui et cet argent
arriverait après l'offre correcte mais ce
sont des projets et des choses et des négociations
qui ont eu lieu avant qu'ils ne se produisent beaucoup
avant pendant et après nous avons continué à parler